a teenager who shoved her friend off a
60ft high bridge will spend as much time
in jail as her friend spent in the
hospital attorneys thought they'd worked
out a plea deal to keep the young woman
out of jail but the judge had another
idea punishment for the teen who pushed
her friend off a bridge 19-year-old
Taylor Smith was in tears as she was
escorted away in handcuffs after being
sentenced to 2 days in jail you cry for
two
days I'm sorry I'm I'm sorry I'm sorry
it's dramatic it's
very bro I'm sorry the wave of emotions
I've had in this 20 seconds clip is
crazy first I watched the clip of her
getting pushed off a bridge then I found
out that they were going to make sure
that this girl doesn't go to jail and
then I found out the judge said
that she going to jail now so I got
happy and then I found out it's for two
days